it's an honor to introduce a close
friend of Ricky Bobby Will Ferrell
[Applause]
how comedian at the Oscars the saddest
man of all
movies may make millions but your name
shall never fall I guess you don't like
laughter
and a smile brings you down
comedian Oscars is the saddest bitterest
alcoholic clown what did you think when
you chose off your pants
and you ran around the racetrack and you
[Music]
did love me
watch it you think that you can change
their wicked game did you think when you
made anchorman they wouldn't call it
lame what a good I thought I'd get to
have dinner with Jeremy Irons we may not
win tonight but we shall win the
ultimate fight and I'm not doing it in a
better pour I mean literally I am going
to fight the nominees I like the way
you're talking okay look at this plan
leo
you think you can date supermodels and
win awards I'm gonna elbows
Alaric's ryan gosling you're all hip and
now I'm gonna break your hip right now
thank Peter O'Toole you're all legendary
in English I don't care I'm gonna beat
you down with my Nickelodeon Award Mark
Wahlberg where are you I won't mess with
you you're actually kind of badass
once again I hope we're cool you are
very talented and a Helen Mirren you are
just hots what party you going to
[Music]
madness must stop there is no need to
fear you can have your cake and eat it
too
just look at my career I didn't cry
I didn't pick so you fight I be
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
don't just speak loud but then you're
just bored mix it up and off yourself
[Music]
he's right I'm gonna reread that script
about the guy who gets lead poisoning
and then Sue's a major corporation
there's not enough in there yes and I'm
gonna take that project about the guy
with no arms and legs who teaches
gangbangers are gonna lose 40 pounds to
play round dinner
that geckos line in film with James
Spader
you can laugh but some days dude you'll
see
Helen dear
come
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you